debout la France anciennement Debout la
République présente des candidats dans 8
cantons Fabien Mettet et pâtissier
aujourd'hui étudiant en histoire et
plaisir roi depuis toujours également
conseillé municipal élu sur la liste de
la mer Joséphine Colmars berger il se
présente pour défendre trois thèmes
politiques une bonne gestion financière
de du département et le bon sens afin de
servir au mieux le bien-être des élus
noirs ce qui m'a donné envie de
rejoindre Debout la République enfin
maintenant debout la France c'est parce
que j'ai enfin j'avais le sentiment que
le pays était mal géré depuis une
quarantaine d'années et que les parties
du gouvernement n'avaient pas réussi à
apporter des solutions adaptées à la
situation et je pense pas non plus que
la situation
viendra des extrêmes
il fera campagne avec Pascal Michard
gérant de société à Plaisir autre binôme
cette fois sur le canton de
Saint-Cyr-l'École Sylvia quant à l'oupi
qui est de toutes les campagnes
politiques et Christophe Pitel élu
conseiller municipal majoritaire à
Villepreux ni système ni extrême lorsque
le gant de campagne
nouveau et qui traînent pas des
casseroles derrière eux parce que après
on est prisonniers soi-même de ses
habitudes et que au conseil général il y
a des c'est le train-train quoi ils sont
entre eux ils font toujours les mêmes
choses les mêmes subventions les mêmes
comportements avoir des subventions qui
soient vraiment utilisées pour pour les
associations et les intérêts des du
canton de Saint-Cyr déjà pour un premier
pour un premier point et surtout
utiliser et pouvoir développer le
département comme il devrait l'être en
dehors du FN qui aujourd'hui est la
seule alternative qui est proposée par
le système contre l'UMP et le PS il y a
une autre solution qui est debout la
France et moi j'essaie de mener ce
terrain là c'est candidats mèneront la
campagne avec comme ils disent les
moyens du bord ils ne disposent pas des
finances des grands partis ils feront
donc beaucoup de tractages pour faire
connaître le parti de Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan
donc